Die Maschine ist pünktlich:
eine Boeing 737.
Ryanair arbeitet nur mit diesem
Flugzeugtyp mit eingebauter Treppe.
Das spart Bodenpersonal.
Und mit dem Prinzip Kostendrücken
hat Ryanair den europäischen
Markt aufgemischt.
An Bord der Maschine aus Dublin:
Vorstandsmitglieder von Ryanair.
Sie wissen, dass der Flughafen Berlin-
Schönefeld aus allen Nähten platzt,
trotzdem wollen sie ihr Geschäft in
der deutschen Hauptstadt ausbauen.
Ich will wissen, ob es stimmt, dass
sie Flüge für unter zehn Euro anbieten.
Ja, man kann für 9 Euro 99 von
hier nach Belfast fliegen – mit Steuern.
Mit Steuern?
Was verdienen Sie damit?
Nichts.
Sie wollen nichts verdienen?
Naja, wenn man 117 Millionen
Passagiere auf 1800 Routen hat,
verdient man nicht mit jedem Kunden.
Der Marketing-Vorstand Kenny
Jacobs ist für zwei Tage in Berlin,
kommt aber nur mit Handgepäck.
Wollen Sie sich nicht
umziehen in den zwei Tagen?
Ich gebe eine Pressekonferenz,
und dann mache ich das
– und werde von der Hüfte aufwärts offiziell
aussehen und untenrum habe ich’s bequem.
Sie sollten erst mal sehen,
wo wir heute Nacht absteigen.
Was wird das sein? 5 Euro 99
mit Frühstück und Steuern?
Nein, es kostet 79 Euro, aber
es ist ein Hostel.
Nein, hier übernachtet er nicht.
Dieses Hotel ist eine der
teuersten Adressen Berlins.
Ryanair hat hier für ein
paar Stunden einen Saal gemietet.
Irgendwie passt das nicht,
weiß auch Kenny Jacobs.
Aber … aber sehr geil diese[s] Hotel.
2017 will Ryanair 19 neue
Routen von Berlin aus fliegen.
Die meisten Maschinen
hat die Fluggesellschaft
in Großbritannien stationiert,
aber das dürfte sich bald ändern.
Berlin und Deutschland
profitieren vom Brexit,
denn der schafft in Großbritannien
ein Gefühl der Unsicherheit.
Das ist ein sehr großer
Markt für Fluglinien,
aber in den nächsten Jahren werden
wir weniger in Großbritannien investieren.
Schon jetzt fliegen 1,6 Millionen
Berlin-Besucher mit Ryanair.
Das will die Fluggesellschaft im nächsten
Jahr mehr als verdreifachen.
Ich frage Kenny Jacobs, warum
ausgerechnet Deutschland
und an welche Kunden er sich wendet.
Wenn du ein Schickimicki-Deutscher
bist mit einem Haufen Geld,
bist du kein typischer Ryanair-Kunde.
Und was ist mit den Mitarbeitern am
Schalter. Bekommen die den Mindestlohn?
Sie bekommen mehr
als den Mindestlohn.
In Berlin arbeiten indirekt rund
450 Menschen für uns.
Sie bekommen ein sehr gutes
Gehalt, denn wäre das nicht so,
würden sie ganz einfach für eine
andere Fluglinie arbeiten
oder für einen anderen Flughafen.
Um bei den Löhnen zu sparen,
arbeitet Ryanair mit Subunternehmern.
Dafür werden sie von europäischen
Gewerkschaften oft kritisiert.
Aber die Iren weisen alle
Vorwürfe weit von sich.
Wie gelingt es der Fluggesellschaft
dann, so günstige Tickets zu verkaufen?
Wo auch immer es geht: an den Flughäfen
oder beim Marketing oder beim Kerosinpreis
überall versuchen wir, die
Kosten so gering wie möglich zu halten.
Der alte Berliner Flughafen Schönefeld soll
extra für die Iren erweitert werden
und selbst dann noch in Betrieb bleiben,
wenn gleich nebenan endlich der
neue Großflughafen BER eröffnet.
Aber der wird und wird nicht fertig.
Dieser Terminal am Flughafen Berlin
Schönefeld funktioniert sehr gut für uns.
Und auch wenn der neue BER eröffnet,
wird er ja schon zu klein sein.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht,
denn es zeigt,
dass immer mehr Menschen
nach Berlin wollen.
Aber der BER wird vermutlich nicht
als die beste deutsche Ingenieursleistung
in die Geschichte eingehen.
Die Touristen stört das nicht.
Die wollen einfach günstig fliegen,
auch wenn sie dafür auf Komfort verzichten.
Darauf setzt Kenny Jacobs.
Nächstes Jahr will Ryanair 5,4 Millionen
Menschen nach Berlin bringen.